so much hesitation when it comes to
calling ghost crickets cause girl what
is that
those crickets I saw one of the names on
there was flower Rangers I don't know
that's kind of funny I don't really have
a problem with that but I don't have a
problem with racial insults if they're
made in jest I think it's totally fine
you can say I think you can make a joke
about whatever race of people or almost
really any attribute if it's made in
good faith and charity I think it's
totally fine now of course if I ever
were to say even the most charitable
obvious joke about any of the Sacred
unspeakable privileged races of people I
would be cast into the outer Darkness
where there's whaling and National teeth
but I don't take offensive that's kind
of fun ghost Cricket that's kind of
funny